Salam alaikum guys how are you doing I
just came across an incredible hadith
you know that the Prophet SAW love saw
him he's not making this stuff up in his
own this is coming from the Creator that
his work Allah so I have Shaykh Matassa
here with me he's going to share this
hadith for anyone who has cinetic nerve
pain many people are suffering from that
he shared this with me incredible story
so you gotta share the hadith and then
give you a live example of someone who
implemented it che can you share this
hadith with us from the messenger Salam
Salam alaikum WA Rahmatullah work at a
chrigel imam abdul majid rahim allah
wahda al-amin hadith he NSF pneumatic
the whole sometta rasoolullah sallallahu
alehiwassallaam a a cold shiver
hurricane Nessa earlier to share in
Arabia to their abou summer to just the
author Lasseter Hz in so miserable
either really Coolio mean just
translation is a blue measure by Malala
narrated hadith that Anna Sydney Malik
said I hear the Messenger of Allah
Ta'ala value seldom saying the cure for
sciatica is the fat from the tale of
Abaddon sheep or wild sheep which should
be melted and divided into three parts
one part to be taken each day on an
empty stomach and I was listening to one
of the Messiah from Egypt that he has
this problem and he was an Imam of
Masjid and subhanAllah he had this
disease and he couldn't even go outside
his house that's next to the Masjid
to leave the prayer so he has he was
sick and really sick and then
subhanAllah he listened you know someone
told him this hadith and he went to
Egypt and he find this sheep and he take
this fat from the barn from the tail of
the sheep and he cooked it for he melted
and treat and one day and he divided to
3/3 and he take each day in the morning
after salat al-fajr before he eat
anything in an empty stomach and after
he finished the third one subhanAllah in
one month mashallah the Sheikh was even
exercising subhanAllah this hadith is
masha'Allah and this is after
excruciating scenario pain that pain
deep pain he went and you were talking
about something that was the hadith
Allah that a sheep who's in its natural
habitat
eating the the things that was designed
to eat it yes that's what it is even the
beasts I seldom mentioned that eat only
from the grass nobody feed it that's why
I called my white sheet yeah nobody fee
and these are the things it's amazing
that we see that now it's kind of should
motivate us because you see a lot of
this even today in science they're
seeing you know nutritional scientists
people are seeing the power of food
there is what they call him the font
they called of one of the fathers they
call Medicine Hippocrates he said let
food be your medicine and medicine be
your food today
we've kind of gone away from that it's
all about you know drugs and whatnot but
we see like fasting now there's so many
studies confirming that fastening the
very old practices giving New Hope to
cancer patients researchers are looking
into the benefits of starving cancer
current state of health in the u.s. is
shocking according to the Journal of the
American Medical Association thirty-five
percent of adults are obese and fifty
percent either have diabetes or
prediabetes
doctors say these diet related health
conditions that also include cancer and
heart disease have many of us headed
toward a future of huge medical bills
even an early death
this idea that you wait until you had
one two three diseases and then you put
a bandaid on top of it it's just a bad
idea that's dr. Valter Longo a leading
researcher on fasting he spoke to us via
Skype about his groundbreaking research
fasting is really a remarkable
intervention meaning there is so much
happening that it is hard to think of
another intervention decree being a
close to to death long as research has
shown that cancer cells are weakened
during a fast I was diagnosed with or
answer the beneficial effects of fasting
and what it can possibly do as it
relates to cancer really caught my eye
so Jay embarked on a fad of his own
under the close supervision of dr.
Angela Fitch of UC health weight loss
center his results were quite profound
when he started Jay's fasted blood
glucose was 87 milligrams which is
considered normal but after the fact it
was down to 67 yeah one of the most
fascinating things was the drop in your
igf-1 which we know is a growth type of
hormone and so it dropped by about 25%
which is a fairly significant job for
just that short amount of days and so
that would potentially make a difference
with things like cancer growth so at one
point my family was having dinner and I
had to go upstairs I was so hungry but
then there was another time when I had
more energy than I knew what to do with
it was really remarkable Jay says he
plans to make periodic fasting part of
his life going forward in his fight
against cancer and you've seen Olympic
athletes also doing the Hazama all right
so this is an invitation to people to
re-explore we have you know these things
that are divinely set from the created
we have them in the Sunnah many people
people have gone away from that and this
is just one example this is this is a
fabulous Adid thank you say for sharing
that with us a little bit radical one
and thank you guys for turning in salaam
a couple i miss me miss me love
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ha ha ha ha ha me learn the Athenian
[Applause]
[Music]
ha ha ha
[Music]